Ласкаво просимо назад до «Квантових обчислень на практиці». Це шостий епізод. Сьогодні ми зосередимося на одній з моїх улюблених
застосувань квантових комп'ютерів — симуляції природи. У цьому епізоді ми розглянемо кроки, необхідні
для вирішення будь-якої задачі квантової динаміки, тобто задачі знаходження того, як опис
квантової системи змінюється з часом. Спочатку ми розглянемо це на загальному рівні, а потім розберемо конкретний приклад
детально — а саме експеримент IBM 2023 року, який продемонстрував квантову корисність. Для короткої мотивації на
початку: одна з найвідоміших історій, яку ми в галузі квантових обчислень розповідаємо знову і знову, —
це історія про лекцію Річарда Файнмана в Caltech у 1959 році, де він фактично
заклав мотивацію для всієї галузі на десятиліття вперед. Виступ називався «Там унизу ще багато місця» —
кумедна назва, але основна ідея полягала в тому, що він стверджував: на мікроскопічному рівні ще так багато цікавої фізики, яку належить
відкрити.
Цей конкретний виступ не привернув особливої уваги аж до 80-х, коли технологія значно просунулась. І Файнман
також уточнював і вдосконалював своє послання з часом. Він повернувся до Caltech у 80-х і представив іншу статтю під назвою
«Симуляція природи за допомогою комп'ютерів», де конкретно сказав, що хоче говорити про можливість точної симуляції, де комп'ютер робитиме рівно те саме, що й природа.
Він хотів поговорити про можливість того, що існує точна симуляція, яку комп'ютер виконуватиме так само, як це робить природа.
Тобто, по суті, позбутися грубих наближень того, що відбувається на атомному рівні, та замінити їх
комп'ютерами, які розуміють і використовують квантову фізику, щоб не просто симулювати те, що робить природа, а емулювати це.
Пригадай цю часову графіку, яку я показував у попередньому епізоді. На одному кінці — задачі, які легко
розв'язати і які не потребують жодного прискорення, яке може запропонувати квантовий підхід. Але на іншому кінці — задачі, які є
дуже складними і потребують відмовостійких квантових машин, яких у нас ще немає.
На щастя, ми вважаємо, що є чимало задач симуляції, які знаходяться тут посередині — у зоні, де ми
зараз можемо працювати. І є багато причин захоплюватися цією перспективою, адже
симуляція природи є основою для багатьох захоплюючих прикладних областей. Назвемо лише кілька. Якби ми могли краще
симулювати природу, ми могли б прискорити відкриття нових матеріалів, створювати кращі фармацевтичні препарати та ліки або
навіть досліджувати нову фізику в галузі фізики частинок чи космології. Але перш ніж ти, чи я, чи хтось інший може спробувати
застосувати квантові обчислення до цих захоплюючих областей, їм потрібно зрозуміти основні кроки
типового робочого процесу на основі симуляції.
По-перше, потрібно визначити квантову систему, яка тебе цікавить. Це дасть тобі інформацію про Гамільтоніан, що керує її часовою
еволюцією, і змістовний опис її початкових властивостей або стану.
Потім тобі потрібно знайти відповідний метод для реалізації часової еволюції цього стану. Маючи ці складові
на місці, наступні кроки пов'язані з проведенням самого експерименту.
Зазвичай вони включають оптимізацію реалізації алгоритму часової еволюції у вигляді quantum circuit, виконання
circuit або circuits на квантовому залізі та постобробку результатів. Тож ми
можемо назвати основні кроки симуляційного експерименту таким чином.
Визначення Гамільтоніану системи, кодування Гамільтоніану, підготовка стану, еволюція стану,
оптимізація circuit, виконання circuit та постобробка.
Але це досить детальні кроки. Пригадай чотири етапи фреймворку Qiskit patterns, який допомагає
нам зрозуміти, як реалізувати рутину в Qiskit: mapping, оптимізація circuit, виконання circuit та
постобробка. Тож ці перші чотири кроки насправді всі входять під парасольку mapping, і саме тому
ми присвятили цілий епізод цьому першому етапу — якщо ти його пропустив, будь ласка, повернись і подивись попередній епізод.
Тепер давай спочатку розберемо, що взагалі означають ці кроки, перш ніж заглиблюватися в код. Отже, перше базове, що нам потрібно
зробити для проведення симуляційного експерименту, — це визначити Гамільтоніан, який описує систему. Іноді —
а насправді часто — вони вже відомі, в інших випадках нам доводиться складати його з розуміння внесків енергії
малих підмножин повної системи, ось так: де hi — це Гамільтоніан, що діє на одну з n підсистем h.
Нам також потрібно зазначити, чи складається система з ферміонів чи бозонів, якщо ми маємо справу з елементарними частинками. Далі
нам потрібно закодувати Гамільтоніан і перевести його в терміни, зрозумілі квантовим комп'ютерам. Часто
ці Гамільтоніани складатимуться з елементарних частинок або спінових систем. Якщо ми симулюємо ферміони чи бозони,
нам потрібно вибрати перетворення кодування, наприклад Йордана–Вігнера або Браві–Кітаєва. Ці перетворення
покажуть нам, як перекласти визначення Гамільтоніану, записаного в термінах початкових компонентів — ферміонів або
бозонів — у оператори Паулі, які легко конвертуються в gates на квантовому комп'ютері. Наприклад, перетворення Йордана–Вігнера,
визначене тут, дає відображення від ферміонних операторів до операторів Паулі. Якщо ми вже маємо справу
зі спін-1/2 системами, що є дуже поширеними, то все чудово — окрім можливих коефіцієнтів нормалізації,
і нам не потрібно використовувати схему кодування. Закодувавши бажаний Гамільтоніан у набір gates квантового комп'ютера,
наступний ключовий крок — визначити відповідний початковий квантовий стан, з якого починати
симуляцію. Цей стан в ідеалі повинен відображати якийсь фізичний зміст або конфігурацію
досліджуваної системи. Наприклад, якщо нас цікавить дослідження енергії основного стану молекули, ми можемо
почати з наближення Хартрі–Фока або іншого легко підготовлюваного стану, що має значне перекриття з істинним
основним станом. Вибір початкового основного стану впливає не лише на збіжність варіаційних алгоритмів,
як-от VQE — варіаційного квантового власника, — але й на точність та ефективність
часової еволюції або вибірки у квантовій фазовій оцінці. По суті, початковий стан є
відправною точкою для обчислення, яка задає сцену для отримання корисних спостережуваних про квантову систему,
яку ми моделюємо. Підготовка довільного n-qubit стану, де ci — це обчислювальні базисні стани, а ai —
WEBVTT
відповідний коефіцієнт кожного стану та умова нормалізації 2 в степені n мінус один — загалом можна підійти так:
ініціалізувати стан оператором o; початковий стан буде стандартним базисним станом всіх нулів, що часто записується
ось так для спрощення. Загалом це вимагає експоненціальної кількості C not gates; часто ми
зацікавлені в конкретному початковому стані системи, і його підготовка може бути реалізована з розумною кількістю
ресурсів. Продуктові стани, наприклад, у яких qubits не заплутані між собою, вимагають лише одно-
qubit операцій. Тепер ми ще не мали можливості поговорити про тротеризацію,
хоча дехто з вас, мабуть, вже знайомий з нею. По суті, тротеризація — це метод обчислення матричної експоненціації, що
використовує наближення для роботи з експоненціальною природою некомутуючих операторів. Коли два оператори, як-от HA
та HB, не комутують, ми повинні застосувати хитрий прийом і по черзі застосовувати відповідні експоненціали
e у степені i ha та e у степені i hb n разів.
Оператори чергування еволюції застосовуються. Я не буду тут доводити це, але поділюся посиланням
на хороший простий доказ цього твердження в описі. Але головний висновок такий: часова еволюція —
важлива частина mapping. Тротеризація розбиває неперервну взаємодію на дискретні кроки, які
можна реалізувати на квантовому комп'ютері. Після генерації тротеризованого circuit ми нарешті завершили
крок mapping. Тепер можемо переходити до оптимізації circuit.
Для цього ось що потрібно зробити. Потрібно визначити розміщення qubits, яке відображає віртуальні qubits
твого circuit на фізичні на залізі. Це необхідно, оскільки залізо може мати певні топології,
що обмежують пряму взаємодію фізичних qubits. Тоді як реалізація
quantum circuit часто передбачає можливість взаємодії будь-якого qubit з будь-яким іншим. Потім нам потрібно вставити
swap gates за потреби для маршрутизації взаємодій між qubits, які не з'єднані. Нам потрібно перекласти
gates у нашому circuit в інструкції архітектури набору інструкцій або ISA,
які можна безпосередньо виконати на залізі. Потім нам потрібно виконати оптимізацію circuit, щоб мінімізувати
глибину circuit та кількість gates. Цей крок також можна виконати на віртуальному circuit — circuit, де qubits
ще не відображені на топологію пристрою. Але пам'ятай, що більшість цього робиться автоматично за тебе в
Qiskit. Ми побачимо точно як — у наступному розділі цієї лекції. Після кроку оптимізації ми готові запустити
circuit за допомогою примітиву. Для більшості симуляційних експериментів тебе цікавить розуміння зміни
певних властивостей системи з часом. Тому, найімовірніше, ти будеш використовувати примітив estimator, оскільки він
дозволяє вимірювати очікувані значення спостережуваних, що відповідають конкретним властивостям. Потім ми
налаштуємо найкращі параметри для estimator, які можуть додати техніки придушення помилок та пом'якшення помилок. Нарешті, ми запустимо
експеримент. Останній крок — постобробка всіх даних. Це витягує виміряні очікувані значення або, якщо
ти використовуєш sampler, вибіркове розподілення ймовірностей в обчислювальному базисі. Якщо все, що потрібно, —
це очікувані значення цікавих спостережуваних, їх можна безпосередньо отримати від примітиву estimator
як у сирому, так і в мітигованому за помилками вигляді. Часто потім використовують виміряні очікувані значення
для інших обчислень інших величин інтересу, що не вимагають квантових обчислень і можуть бути
обчислені на класичному комп'ютері.
Тепер ми розглянемо реальний приклад з дуже впливової статті, яку IBM опублікувала кілька років тому, під назвою
«Свідчення корисності квантових обчислень до відмовостійкості». Ця стаття, яку ми ласкаво скорочуємо як
«стаття про корисність», стала дуже впливовою в галузі квантових обчислень майже одразу після публікації.
Загальна теза статті полягає в тому, що шумний квантовий комп'ютер видав точні результати або очікувані значення,
використовуючи 127 qubits та 2880 gates, поза можливостями грубої
сили обчислення, яка є точною симуляцією quantum circuits, виконаних залізом. Ця робота була
також важливою, оскільки показала, що квантовий комп'ютер можна використовувати для перевірки або порівняння результатів з іншими
наближеними класичними методами для квантових симуляцій, такими як алгоритми тензорних мереж, де рішення
не було відоме апріорі. Що також досить круто — тепер інші, використовуючи квантові системи IBM
у хмарі та Qiskit, можуть самостійно відтворити та перевірити ці результати.
Я покажу тобі, як це зробити. Отже, для цього прикладу ми трохи детальніше розглянемо
кроки, що стосуються відображення цієї задачі у входи, зрозумілі квантовому пристрою. У цьому випадку ми будемо
симулювати динаміку загального намагнічення системи магнітних дипольних спінів на ґратці в
присутності зовнішнього магнітного поля. Систему можна описати моделлю Ізінга з поперечним магнітним полем.
Ми моделюємо це за допомогою параметризованого quantum circuit, де параметри відповідають регульованому значенню
спін-спінової або z-взаємодії та силі магнітного поля X. Тепер,
ця серія називається «Квантові обчислення на практиці». Тому ми також обговоримо процедури в цьому експерименті,
які ми впровадимо, щоб зробити результати якомога кращими. Далі ми обговоримо, як видалити
погані qubits або qubits з низькою вірністю gates чи часами декогеренції, що могло б суттєво вплинути на
експериментальні результати. Ці погані qubits можуть виникати через погану попередню калібровку
або дворівневі системи, що взаємодіють з qubit. Видалення деяких qubits з рідної топології заліза відповідає
розгляду системи на ґратці, описаної результуючою топологією. Ми також обговоримо створення
параметризованого quantum circuit, який реалізує часову еволюцію системи за допомогою тротеризації.
Для цього важливо визначити заплутуючі шари, які є критичною частиною основної техніки пом'якшення помилок,
яку ми використаємо пізніше. Тож зараз я хочу переконатися, що ти, глядачу, знаєш,
що можеш слідкувати за всім, про що я зараз буду говорити, у підручнику, посилання на який є нижче, та на IBM
платформі навчання квантових технологій. У цьому підручнику ти можеш помітити, що ми створили серію допоміжних
функцій на початку ноутбука, до яких можемо звертатися пізніше, щоб трохи спростити собі життя. Я хочу згадати їх
зараз — не тому, що це частина офіційного чи формального процесу, а тому, що саме так часто роблять експериментатори
у реальному житті, щоб допомогти їм проводити такі типи експериментів. І це також показує нам, як ми збираємося розбити нашу
задачу ще далі. Функції, які ми визначаємо в ноутбуці, такі. Remove qubit couplings.
Define qubit couplings. Construct the layer couplings. Construct entangling layers. І нарешті, define trotterized
circuit. Далі поговоримо про шарові зв'язки, які допомагають визначити, як qubits
взаємодіють з сусідами під час симуляції. Наші квантові пристрої використовують так зване важке шестикутне
розташування. Це особливий шаблон з'єднання qubits. У цьому розташуванні ми можемо згрупувати з'єднання, які називаються ребрами, у три
окремі набори, де жодні два з'єднання в одному наборі не мають спільного qubit. Це
важливо, тому що на реальному квантовому комп'ютері ми не можемо запускати двохqubit gates одночасно, якщо вони задіюють
той самий qubit. Кожен qubit може брати участь лише в одному gate одночасно. Розділивши
всі з'єднання на три шари, ми можемо застосовувати двохqubit gates по всьому пристрою за три
раунди, гарантуючи, що жоден qubit не використовується більш ніж в одному gate на шар. Ці
gates реалізують ZZ-взаємодію з моделі Ізінга і повторюються на кожному кроці симуляції, що називається
кроком тротера. Твірлінг модифікує шум у пристрої так, що навіть проста модель шуму
має шанс бути точною. Це також уможливлює точне вивчення моделі шуму і використання отриманої
інформації в техніках пом'якшення помилок.
Далі нам потрібно видалити погані qubits зі списку можливих фізичних qubits, які ми можемо використовувати для
експерименту. Як я вже казав, qubit може стати поганим з різних причин. Іноді це просто погана
калібровка — проста помилка, яку можна виправити просто повторною калібровкою.
Іноді це трохи складніше і пов'язано з тим, що ми називаємо TLS — двохрівневим поверхневим
дефектом, який призводить до флуктуацій параметрів qubit та релаксації. Це можна
вирішити, трохи прогрівши всю систему, а потім охолодивши її знову. Але це займає деякий час і неможливо зробити
через хмару. Тому поки що найпростіше — просто виключити їх зі списку можливих фізичних
qubits, які ми будемо використовувати. Ти можеш легко визначити, які qubits поводяться не так, як очікується, на платформі IBM Quantum.
Там можна побудувати характеристики qubits або завантажити їх як CSV. Потім створи список усіх
qubits, які хочеш виключити, і просто видали їх зі списку всіх фізичних qubits на пристрої.
Добре. Тепер продовжимо з нашим кроком mapping — генерацією нашого тротеризованого circuit. Як ми вже показали
раніше, тротеризація дискретизує часову еволюцію в серію кроків, і нам потрібно вирішити, скільки кроків.
Виберемо шість тут. Але загалом стратегія полягає в тому, щоб збалансувати так звану помилку тротера — це
алгоритмічна помилка наближення — з помилкою, що виникає від декогеренції. Більше кроків тротера зменшує помилку наближення,
але вимагає глибших quantum circuits, які зазнають більшого шуму декогеренції. Ми визначимо
circuit у термінах параметра theta, який є силою зовнішнього магнітного поля, шарових зв'язків та
кількості кроків і qubits, і, звичайно, backend пристрою. Через
залежність намагнічення системи від сили зовнішнього магнітного поля цікаво
виконати симуляцію при різних значеннях сили магнітного поля, які переводяться в різні кути RX обертання
для RX у circuit. Тепер, маючи згенерований circuit, перейдемо до його оптимізації.
Перший крок тут — визначити менеджер проходів. Пам'ятай, що в контексті Qiskit SDK транспіляція означає
процес перетворення вхідного circuit у форму, придатну для виконання на квантовому пристрої.
Транспіляція зазвичай відбувається у послідовності кроків, що називаються проходами transpiler. Менеджер проходів — це об'єкт,
який зберігає список проходів transpiler і може виконувати їх на circuit. Створи менеджер проходів, ініціалізувавши об'єкт менеджера проходів
зі списком проходів transpiler. Зрештою, наш менеджер проходів
створить ISA circuit — circuit, який повинен бути написаний у термінах архітектури набору інструкцій backend,
що описує circuit і gates, рідні для backend, але не містить інформації про часові параметри, необхідні для запуску
circuit. Тепер ми готові виконати наш circuit — це крок три у Qiskit patterns. Як зазначалося раніше, ми
обов'язково будемо використовувати estimator як наш примітив для цього експерименту, оскільки хочемо виміряти загальне
намагнічення системи, а оцінка очікуваного значення спостережуваних — це те, для чого estimator
і призначений. На цьому кроці також буде важливо вказати наші параметри пом'якшення помилок. Ми використаємо екстраполяцію нульового шуму,
щоб отримати найкращі можливі результати. Зокрема, у підручнику ти побачиш, що ми вказуємо два або більше
значень коефіцієнта шуму, при яких оцінюються екстрапольовані моделі, та вказуємо
імовірнісне підсилення помилок як наш параметр підсилення. Тепер, імовірнісне
підсилення помилок, або PA, справді було обраним методом пом'якшення помилок тут, оскільки воно масштабується значно
краще, ніж інші варіанти. І це важливо, коли ми працюємо на рівні 100+ qubits.
І нарешті, запустимо експеримент — це займе деякий час, але поки що давай звернемося до даних,
збережених у черзі з підручника. Ми розглянемо метадані, звертаючи особливу увагу на шарові gates та
мітиговані шари, оскільки ми збираємося використати їх для видалення купи помилок з наших сирих даних. Ми майже готові
побудувати наші остаточні результати. Але перед цим давай швидко додамо тут вставку про те, що саме мається на увазі під нульовою
екстраполяцією шуму, або ZNE. Ми коротко розглядали це в попередніх епізодах, але для повторення: нульова екстраполяція шуму
— це техніка пом'якшення помилок, яка усуває ефекти невідомого шуму під час виконання circuit, який можна
масштабувати відомим способом. Вона припускає, що очікувані значення масштабуються з шумом за відомою функцією, показаною тут, де
параметри lambda вказують силу шуму і можуть бути підсилені. Ми можемо реалізувати ZNE такими кроками.
По-перше, підсили шум circuit для кількох коефіцієнтів шуму: lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3 і так далі. Запусти кожен підсилений за шумом circuit, щоб виміряти
очікуване значення a від lambda 1, a від lambda 2 тощо. Потім екстраполюй назад до межі нульового шуму —
очікуваного значення a від нуля.
Головна складність успішної реалізації ZNE — мати точну модель шуму в очікуваному значенні
та підсилювати шум відомим способом.
Є три поширені способи реалізації підсилення помилок для ZNE: масштабування тривалості імпульсів за допомогою калібровки,
повторення gates у тотожніх циклах та додавання шуму через вибірку каналів Паулі.
Останнє ми називаємо PA. Імовірнісне підсилення помилок є найкращим вибором тут, оскільки розтягування імпульсів є дуже
обчислювально затратним. Складання gates не має теоретичних гарантій щодо збереження зміщення шуму. Але PA можна
застосовувати до будь-якого circuit, який можна запустити з рідними коефіцієнтами шуму, але вимагає вивчення моделі шуму. PA припускає
ту саму пошарову модель шуму, що й імовірнісне скасування помилок.
Однак вона уникає накладних витрат на вибірку, що масштабуються експоненційно з шумом circuit. Щоб вивчити модель шуму,
спочатку потрібно визначити унікальні шари двохqubit операцій у circuit.
Для кожного шару зроби Паулі-твірлінг двохqubit gates, щоб гарантувати, що шум добре описується моделлю шуму загасання.
Повторюй тотожні пари шарів на різних глибинах і нарешті підбери вірність або помилку для кожного каналу шуму. І
звичайно, хоча я рекомендую певною мірою розуміти цей метод, робити це вручну в Qiskit
набагато простіше, як показано в підручнику. Тепер нарешті давай подивимось на побудовані дані. Пунктирна
сіра лінія показує точні результати, отримані наближеними класичними методами з похибкою наближення,
що збігається до низького порогу. Як ти можеш бачити, сирі дані для різних коефіцієнтів шуму, які ми вибрали на
початку, досить далеко від цієї пунктирної лінії. Суцільна синя лінія показує дані з урахуванням нашої обробки ZNE.
І одразу видно, що вона набагато ближче до точних результатів.
Підсумовуючи: шумні значення показують значне відхилення від точних значень.
Мітиговані значення близькі до точних значень, що демонструє корисність техніки мітигації на основі PA.
І це по суті завершує цей епізод. Щоб швидко підсумувати, чого ми навчилися: квантова симуляція — це одна
з найперспективніших прикладних областей у короткостроковій та середньостроковій перспективі.
Вона має широкий спектр застосувань — від фармацевтики до фізики високих енергій,
матеріалознавства та іншого. Стаття про корисність від IBM, опублікована у 2023 році, вказала
шлях до можливості використання квантових комп'ютерів для наукових відкриттів. І ми детально опрацювали
відповідний підручник, що додається до цієї статті. Кроки для розв'язання задачі симуляції від початку
до кінця є відносно прямолінійними, особливо коли звикнеш до них. І моя надія, що ти
зможеш відтепер використовувати це відео та підручник як посібник для ще більшої кількості задач симуляції в майбутньому.
Дякую за перегляд, і побачимося наступного разу в «Квантових обчисленнях на практиці».